les directions roland garros la
rencontre vient tout juste de s'achever
et gaël monfils n'a pas réalisé
l'exploit il a été battu il ya quelques
minutes par le suisse rodger federer en
demi finale et ce en quatre sets 6 2 5 7
6 3 7 5
le français vous allez voir opposé au
numéro un mondial une étonnante
résistance chaque jeu a été extrêmement
disputée on voit tout de suite le résumé
de la rencontre avec serge de juin juste
après nous serons avec le champion en
direct à peine entré sur le court gaël
monfils est gêné par un problème de
verre de contact ils retournent aux
vestiaires puis rate ses services et
donne l'avantagé à rodger federer contre
le numéro un mondial
cela ne pardonne pas déstabilisé gaël
monfils perd le premier set 6 2 dès le
début du deuxième le jeune français
retrouve sa vision ses esprits et son
punch
il résiste au maître du tennis mondial
le virtuose de l'instrument accord doter
d'une couverture exceptionnelle du
terrain gaël monfils frappe des balles
qui semble impossible à renvoyer la
partie s'équilibre
l'enfant de la martinique et de la
guadeloupe soulève l'enthousiasmé du
public
le deuxième set est très disputés à
l'image de cet échange
souvent privé de sa première balle de
service le suisse devient vulnérable
gaël monfils en profite 7 5 il égalise à
une manche partout
son adversaire qui lui n'en est pas à sa
première demi finale du tournoi du grand
chelem serre le jeu et empoche le
troisième set
le quatrième est serré cela se joue sur
quelques points
cette attaque défense tournent à
l'avantagé du plus offensif
la victoire finale de rodger federer en
quatre sets
la fin de la belle aventure de gaël
monfils
federer pour allons proposer un nadal
dimanche en finale monfils perd contre
plus fort que lui mais prend rendez vous
avec roland garros et le gotha du tennis
car il n'a que 21 ans